goodbye Philadelphia and goodbye family
hello coffee on a Tuesday in HD blocked
well
[Music]
so last week 48 civilian protesters were
killed in Tahrir Square Cairo in Egypt
2,000 were wound to nine months ago the
square looked like this did we get that
out of pretty mouth so what happened
maybe you know the story of ancient
Egypt maybe mr. Gehrke spent three whole
weeks on it in fifth grade and you
learned about pharaohs and hieroglyphics
and pyramids which you later made for a
project out of foam board or cardboard
or sugar cubes or cheese at the very
least you know about it and maybe you
thought all that was fascinating but the
story of modern Egypt is just as
incredible and it's so much at the heart
of the cultural shift happening in the
Middle East right now that we ought to
get an idea of how it goes well it goes
like this the man looks at Egyptian
military caste held power in Egypt from
1250 to 1517 when the Turks of the
Ottoman Empire based them out and took
control they kept it until 1798 when
Napoleon bitched them out and finally in
1801 Napoleon himself was bitched by the
Brit now the Brits were only there
because the French were so when the
French were expelled the Brits left to
meeting a vacuum of power which the
Turks and the Mamluks jumped to fill in
the and he was neither turk nor Mameluke
who seized control but rather an
Albanian commander who played the two
against each other called Muhammad Ali
no not that one or that one that one
here is the beginning of modern Egypt
18:05 Ali began reforming the country
into a modern state building its
military its industry and its educated
bureaucracy basically from scratch it
more than any man ever had for a Jif
single-handedly sparking the Arab
Renaissance or the alnahdha
he won some battles in gained some
territory and lost some battles of lost
some territory he got older he got
paranoid he went crazy and he died his
son assumed power that he died shortly
after that his nephew assumed power and
he was killed and his fourth son then
his grandson
his great-grandson lesser men by the
1880s Egypt had become completely
dependent on England and France for a
healthy account and when they tried to
break away England sent in its forces
and occupied the country it stayed under
occupation until after the First World
when the walked party led by sod so cool
asked for independence from Britain
something they thought they had been
promised for their sacrifice in the war
the Brits were like no they exiled Zagal
to Malta and this sparked a grassroots
uprising the revolution of 1919 the
result of this was the official
independence of Egypt in 1992 and the
drafting of a first constitution a year
later that their independence was
largely in the agent was now a monarchy
with a king backed by the British and
subservient to the British Council Jim
he died before World War two and was
replaced with 16 year old King Farouk
the first this guy was a British puppet
the Brits used Egypt as a base of Allied
operations all throughout world war ii
Magana from germany the Soviet Union and
the United States all added to
anti-british sentiment in 1948 Egypt
blundered through the arab-israeli war
losing 78% of Palestine in the process
the country blamed you guessed it for
and a movement called the Free Officers
led by Mohammed digweed and the mall
Nasser orchestrated a military coup in
1952 Egypt's second twentieth-century
revolution they overthrew Farouk tossed
away the 1923 constitution and declared
Egypt are repops ending up a one-party
system made of all three officers called
the liberation round ugly was declared
the first president of each a drafted a
new constitution secular in nature which
a group called the Muslim Brotherhood of
two years later the Muslim Brotherhood
was outlawed as an illegal political
organization years after that Maghrib
was replaced with Nasser as the second
president of each and his first action
was to announce the nationalization of
the Suez Canal this man-made canal was a
trade superhighway for the middlee
England France were pissed because they
used the canal so much that they hatched
a plan with Israel
[Music]
at the Portsmouth Naval Base Britton
prepares for the worst in the Suez
Crisis it was a secret plan and a stupid
plan and they should have told the u.s.
because when I found out he was pissed
knighted States was not consulted in any
way about any phase of these actions the
US was like get the fuck out of there
dude and Nasser's prestige was cemented
by a proxy victory of the Suez Canal
crisis he ruled for another 18 years
promoted pan-arabism all throughout his
term led the six-day war against Israel
which he lost embarrassingly and then he
died quietly his vice president Anwar
el-sadat succeeded him as the third
president of Egypt Sadat's most notable
accomplishment was his participation in
the Camp David Accords with President
Carter and Prime Minister David
ben-gurion which led to the eventual
peace treaty with Israel treaty which is
still honored today but Sadat and Egypt
were ostracized for this from the Arab
League opposition came Adam from alsa
and during a military parade on the 6th
of October 1981 four assassins broke
through the barricades and killed his
vice president Hosni Mubarak assumed
power as the fourth and last president
of Egypt Mubarak maintained the peace
agreement with Israel while salvaging
Egypt's relationship with the Arab
League being readmitted in 1989 he
privatized much of the economy and Egypt
saw extreme growth in the 1990 partly
due to the fourteen billion dollars have
got in debt relief for its participation
in the Gulf War
but Mubarak was an autocrat like Sadat
before him and Nasser before him he
reigned unchallenged for 26 years and in
the first election that saw a second
candidate in 2005 that candidate a man
hour was in prison and we can't forget
that Egypt has been under emergency law
since 1967 which just spends
constitutional rights legalized
censorship and extends police power
under Mubarak there were repeated
occurrences of police brutality and
severe corruption among government
officials who were hoarding massive
amounts of wealth for themselves by 2011
after a severe worldwide economic crisis
the
Oshin came to a head and we watched day
by day as protesters stormed Tahrir
Square and demanded Mubarak set down
after 29 years inspired by a popular
uprising in Tunisia thousands of
Egyptians took to the streets demanding
the ouster of President Hosni Mubarak Oh
whew 800 years of history plenty you can
see how Egypt has jested how it moved
from a tribal state to a sultan in to a
kingdom to a republic you can see in
Egypt the wave of Middle Eastern history
as it tries to crash on the shore of
freedom and democracy but you can also
see that their history is one of blood
and ferment LED exclusively by military
leaders and always in flux it's the
military who has control and Gaz the
interim leaders a Supreme Council of 20
generals postpones a civilian ruled
government to the dismay of men protests
vegan again dozens have been killed the
council apologizes but it falls on deaf
ears monday saw the start of a long
process of parliamentary elections which
won't deliver a new president until mid
to late 2012 in the meantime the council
stays in charge who will step forward
the Muslim Brotherhood made legal again
after 57 years and sure to be a big
winner in the first round of
parliamentary election will it be
leftists revolutionaries or just
successors of MU bar nobody really knows
how it's all going to turn out but maybe
this is the most important statistic
it's how much 40 percent of Egypt makes
per day
Egyptians want change but they need
stability and with change there is no
stability and with stability there is
little change how do they find democracy
and who will be the stewards of
revolution in egypt and the movement and
a movement called the three officers led
by muhammad and a movement palpable and
a movement called the free officers led
by Mohammed